le plr donatien transformée pour
l'occasion et un public amateur au
rendez vous samedi soir les coups de
pied de poing de jeunes ou de coude ont
été distribués dans le plus grand
respect de la boxe thaïlandaise
comme dans ce combat féminin où sandrine
l'indoor du full fight club de ducos
s'est imposé devant son adversaire de la
guadeloupe
une satisfaction pour cette jeune
boxeuse à la recherche de la compétition
respect sion mais qui sort vainqueur
heureux mais si tu perds ou tu gagnes
sort vainqueur même kate dans les joutes
masculine aux boxeurs locaux ont pu
donner la réplique à les combattants
venus de l'hexagone
un temps fort pour ces sportifs en
manque de compétition sur le territoire
et qui souhaite mettre en lumière une
discipline encore trop souvent montré
par rapport à l'échelle nationale devoir
de le rencontrer si on est surtout
présente pour moi c'est pas la première
fois pour certains aussi pour tous
mais le fait qu'ils aient dit comme ça
on a besoin de ça fait plus de cinq ans
car rien mais ce gars là est aussi
l'occasion d'observer l'élite comme
charles françois di carli tôt s'il faut
à champion de france du froid champions
européens huit fois champion du monde
face à time inc en laye asri du kenshi
le martiniquais a fait preuve de
puissance mais surtout d'expérience en
appuyant sur l'une des faiblesses de son
adversaire savait qu'elle allait rentrer
en corps à corps donc des couches de
laisser faire je laissais j'ai un peu
des risques mais je savais qu'ils
allaient se fatiguer et après le 4ème
round j'ai pu j'ai pu terminer mon
travail de sape sur sur ces gens mon
travail de deux points à distance qui
est capté par payer une victoire acquise
au quatrième round sur décision de
l'arbitré beau symbole pour la vôtre
finlandais en martinique qui peut
s'inspirer de charles françois pour
viser les sommets de la discipline
c'était à garoua de loops et martin est
même passé compliqué donc là on l'a fait
une fois par année
après cinq ans de vide dans l'univers de
la boxe thaïlandaise
la caribbean world unite souhaite
s'imposer comme l'un des concepts
pérenne afin de faire briller les
compétiteurs locaux